Last time my, uh, I wrote down
the Schwartz Shield metric, uh,
which was the sort of culmination of
the theoretical part of the, uh, uh,
uh,
of this section of the course.
And I realized as I was talking to
some of you afterwards about, uh,
uh, about some of the implications
of this that, uh, the way I,
one of the ways in which I wrote it
down might've been a little confusing.
So let me write it down again.
Uh, and I'll say a couple things.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to write it down, uh,
with a little r instead of a capital r.
And I'll tell you why in just a minute.
Obviously it doesn't matter.
I've just changed the notation slightly.
And the reason I want to do this is
because I want to emphasize that this are
the little r Wood I've now written down
as a little r in this equation is not
the radius of the object are,
is just a coordinator.
Yeah.
It, uh, it can be anything. It's
not the radius of the object, uh,
for which the mass is giving
you the swatch drilled radius.
The Schwartz wrote radius is ups
is a very specific ratings. Uh,
R sub s is equal to two
g m oversee squared.
So that's a specific number or is the
little r here is just to coordinate and so
is uh,
fi and theta,
which combined into this thing
which I've called Omega and t. Uh,
and so, uh, if you have an object
of mass am and radius,
I'll give a,
I'll call that a r sub zero,
just to make sure that you understand
that this is the radius of the object.
The radius of the object
doesn't come into this metric.
The mass does because the mass, uh, uh,
turns into the Schwab radius and that's
part of, that's part of the equation.
But the radius of the object doesn't
matter. And so if you then ask,
well what is a black hole? A black
hole is something in which, uh,
the radius of the object is less
than the Schwartz Shield radius.
Because if that's true,
then there is some coordinate are some
little are where a little R is equal to r
s and then if you go up into in
into these equations here, very,
these very strange things happen when
little r is equal to rs. Yes. Question.
Oh, you're right. You're right. It has
to be the other way around. I'm sorry
this has to be squared. You're
right on both counts. Good. Uh,
s over our rs over our,
yes,
it better be that way because
our s over our in uh, in,
in the normal part of spaces less
than one. So thank you very much.
Sorry about that.
MMM.
Okay. I think we're all, I think we're all
right. Are we all right? Yeah. Good. Uh,
okay,
so there is some r where r is equal to
rs and then these very bizarre things
start to happen.
If our zero,
the radius of the actual object is
bigger than a true our trilled radius,
then that isn't true.
There's no r where R is equal to r s then,
okay.
No are equal to rs.
Now you might think that somewhere inside
the object there would be a little R,
which is equal to the Schwartz
drilled radius. But that isn't a,
that turns out not to be right
either because the relevant m
the relevant mass. Oh, sure.
Uh,
oh yeah.
Okay. So yeah, let me get this back.
The relevant mass, uh, is the mass
okay.
Inside
are,
so if you're,
uh,
if you've got some mass and
like this and you're outside,
if you're here then the
whole of the mass counts.
But if you're sitting inside this thing,
then the only mass that
counts is this mass here.
Uh,
and so for our,
for coordinates,
for positions inside the object,
then the relevant mass that you put into
the equation is less than the mass of
the whole object.
And the consequence of that is that as
you go further and further inside the
thing, the mass becomes less and less. Uh,
and the Schwab chilled radius
becomes less and less. And so it, uh,
if the total size of the object is
greater than the Schwab chilled radius,
then there is no position,
uh,
inside the thing,
which is less than the Schwartz drilled
radius because the relevant mass
decreases and soldiers,
the Schwartz would radius as you go in
toward the center of the object. So,
uh, I just wanted to, uh,
to make sure you understood,
uh, that the, the key to
using this metric is that the,
the, this, our term in it
tells you where you are.
It has nothing to do with
the size of the object,
and you become a black hole when the
size of the object is smaller than the
Schwab chilled radius.
Because under those circumstances,
there's some position or set of positions,
uh,
where you can be inside the Schwab,
chilled a radius,
and therefore all of these very
exotic effects start to happen.
Questions on this
or have I just baffled you further?
Okay.
Well, we'll see. Sorry. Oh, no. Yes.
This is the radius of the
object, son. His son has a,
has a.in the middle. Not that you
could tell with my handwriting, but uh,
okay. I don't know whether that
was helpful or not, but, uh,
I felt the need to say yes
please. Oh, this right here.
Yeah. So, uh, uh,
the situation is that what is the relevant
m to put into this equation? This,
this is true by the way,
in Newtonian physics also,
if you're inside an object,
then the mass outside of your position,
this stuff doesn't count toward
the M and you only want to count,
uh,
the mass inside of where you are.
Yeah. So this whole circle
is an object object, uh,
with,
uh,
mass and some with some
mass in some radius.
But now you're asking the question,
what happens if you're
somewhere inside this thing?
Yes. No. The dot. Well,
the dotted line could be anything.
You're at some position inside and this,
the dotted line is,
uh,
the radius at which you are at
which your particular position?
No, it's just, it's just wherever
you are inside the thing,
less mass counts than you think it's going
to because it's only the stuff inside
your own radius that counts toward,
toward the metric or toward
the gravitational force.
In the Newtonian thing you
can be at whatever point you
choose to be inside here,
you can draw this same thing.
And the,
the point of this is that if you are
now down in here where you thought the
Schwartz Shield radius was going to be
for the whole of this mass, in fact,
the Schwartz showed radius is still
going to be inside your position because
much less mass will count toward it.
This isn't helping. I can tell by
the look on your face. Um, okay.
Let me try again.
Okay, here's, here's an object, okay?
And this object has r has a radius bigger
than neutral Nutro Archbold radius,
and it's got some mass. Okay, so now
I'm going to draw in dotted lines.
It's Schwartz Shield radius
that's inside here. Okay?
Now supposing you're inside this object,
supposing you're living here,
uh,
then at that point, you, I,
I draw this sort of interior radius here.
And,
uh, if I'm at this point,
then I ask what is the,
the Schwartz Shield radius
that goes into the metric
for something that's sitting
inside for person x here?
And the answer to that is it's actually
smaller than the Schwartz showed radius
of the entire object because less mass
counts only this mass counts towards the
Schwab trilled radio.
So there's some part of the object
whose mass no longer counts because it's
outside your position.
And so as I move in here
to some interior point,
the Schwartzwald radius that is
appropriate for me to use become smaller.
Does that make more sense?
Ah,
so if I was a black, if it
was a black hole, right? Okay.
So now let's do the opposite case.
Good question
is less than the Schwab chilled radius.
So now here's my object and here's
the Schwartz chilled radius.
That's the difference,
right? And therefore, uh, uh,
and the consequence of this,
by the way,
is that this whole object sinks
down to a point because remember,
things inside the Schwab showed radius
have to contract down to a point.
So I can't be part way through it,
no matter what I do.
Dan, you know, if I'm outside this, uh,
this tiny little thing, if I'm here,
I have the same short showed radius
because all of the masses interior to my
position.
So the key thing is,
is the objects smaller or bigger
than its own? Schwab, chilled radius,
all the mass is going to be
closer. All yeah, all, well,
all the math,
if the,
if the radius of the object is
smaller than a truck showed radius,
then all the masses inside the Schwartz
drilled radius and any point in our
universe where,
you know,
and so all are greater than
our s is out somewhere.
And,
and it doesn't matter where you are,
all that mass counts because it's all
inside the Schwartzwald radius anyway.
And then when you get to this point,
you have this magic moment where our
equals r s and everything blows up.
Right.
And that can't happen here because as
you move in in the middle of the object,
the Schwartz showed radius strengths
down away from you as you get in because
less and less mass counts counts
towards it. Therefore it gets smaller.
Yes. Would it be possible
to have an optic that
there,
there would be a point at which you do it?
Okay.
So could you have some incredible density
gradient where you're actually gaining
more, uh, uh,
you're actually catching up to the
Schwab chilled radius as you go in,
in principle,
yes.
But if you work out what that
density gradient would have to be,
it would be incredibly, uh,
it would be incredibly steep.
Remember there was a problem set at
some point where we discovered that, uh,
the last mass,
there isn't a black hole,
the denser it has to be in order to
be inside each war, chilled radius.
So as you're losing mass,
as you get down, uh, uh,
in here,
the amount by which it has to be denser
on the inside goes up really sharply.
Uh, but yes, such a thing can be
imagined, imagined, for example, uh,
a black hole with an atmosphere.
Imagine there's some orange,
some just gas floating around out here.
If you think of that as one object,
then when you're outside the gas,
if you think of the outer edge of the
gas is the edge of the object, then, uh,
that's not a black hole. And if you
come on, you, you know, if you go down,
sink down into the atmosphere,
eventually you'll find it.
So that's an incredibly steep,
uh,
density change because you've gone
from an atmosphere to some object.
So in principle, that's
possible, uh, in, uh,
any kind of real object
that's holding itself up,
probably not because the density
gradient would have to be so severe.
Yes.
How would this work?
How does it work for non spherical
objects? Excellent. Uh, okay. So,
uh,
let's see.
What happens is, uh, if you have
a non spherical at first of all,
the gravitational forces are
sufficiently strong near a,
if you're anything close to a black hole
that you're likely to end up spherical.
The only way you don't is if
you're spinning because then,
uh, then you know, you, you,
you bulge out at the center, uh,
spinning black holes exist. They
have a different metric and the, uh,
uh,
the angular term becomes important because
you're spinning around and there's,
and it's a different metric and the shape
of the event horizon where R is equal
to r s or the equivalent in this
other metric is non spherical.
And so you can have nonspiritual event
horizons if the thing is spinning because
that has the effect of making the
mass distribution different. Uh,
and there as this is called occur
black hole, it has occur metric k,
e r r a and that's a different metric
and it's got a whole other set of terms
that have to do with the row, with the
rotational, the angular component. Uh,
but again, the same thing happens
when you get to some place.
All the terms blow up.
Uh,
but it's a non spherical
surface where that occurs.
You have to do it in cylindrical
coordinates. It becomes a mess.
Not that it isn't a mess already.
Other questions?
All right.
Um,
let me go back to the effects of,
uh,
of general relativity. Uh, we've
already done one of these. The,
so what I'm going to talk
about is the Post Newtonian
gravitational
effect.
So these are things where it just barely
starts to deviate away from what the
predictions of Newton's
laws would be. So, uh,
just to, uh, just to go back,
if you take that metric and you,
uh,
and you kind of expand it in,
in small quantities
where the, where the, uh,
Schwab short radius is much,
much smaller than wherever you are.
And you take the first
term of the expansion, uh,
mathematically it turns into the
same things as Newton's laws. Uh,
and so when you're,
when you're out there in more or less
flat space or close to flat space,
uh, then Newton's laws still apply because
the expansion of the metric gives you
the,
it gives you the exact same result.
As the gravitational forces become larger,
you start to get a post Newtonian terms
and things start to be a little bit
different from Newton. Uh, and
we've already had one of these. Uh,
so post Newtonian effect number one
is the precession of the Para Helion,
where unlike the prediction for Newton,
the orbit doesn't exactly repeat. It
sort of moves on a little bit each time.
And you get one of these nice sort
of spiral graph patterns, uh, as,
as the orbit graduate
as an elliptical orbit.
Gradually precesses boot gradually
moves around. So that was the first one.
Um, and that was the first one
that was seeing, that was seen, uh,
in mercury,
which is the planet you would expect to
see such a thing because it's closest to
the, uh, and therefore our s over ards,
the largest number for mercury, uh, uh,
for any planet in the solar
system. So, uh, mercury.
Yeah,
no,
it actually turns out to have been known
before Einstein actually worked out the
general relativity. Okay. So now
post Newtonian effect number two
is the deflection of light.
The whole idea remember,
is that there's the,
is that gravity works cause he curved
space and objects moving along this curve
space appear to have curved
trajectories. That's true of light. Also,
light is also moving
across this curve space.
So there's a prediction
in general relativity, uh,
that if you shine light
near and a massive object,
it's the path that that light
will take. It's curved, uh,
does if the light being gravitational,
he attracted by this object. So,
um,
let's see here.
Imagine the following situation here are
you, you're, you're observing something.
Here's a star.
Uh,
and the path that light
takes to this star,
uh, from the star to your eye
as some kind of straight line.
And so that's where you
perceive the start to be. Now,
supposing that along that
between you and this star,
uh,
there's,
yeah,
some object. So here's a,
here's an object with mass m.
So a massive object. Now, uh,
because the path is going to curve,
uh,
the path of the light takes from the
start to your eye is going to now look
something like this
and it's deflected by
the presence of the mass,
which curves the space that had 10.
That means you think,
because you're interpreting this as if
the light is coming straight towards you,
you think the star is here
or it appears to be, uh,
there because you say,
all right, what is the,
what is the angle at which the
light is coming into my eye?
It's coming from there and
you don't realize that the,
that the star is actually over there
and the light has gone up toward the
ceiling and bent deck down to your eye.
So it's as if I'm looking up there
and seeing the exit side, uh,
because the light from the exit sign
has gone up to the ceiling being bent
around by some black hole or something up,
up to up at the top of the classroom
and come back down to my eye. Yeah.
On the other side of
the, ah, it is possible.
Yes, it is possible. Uh,
in this particular case,
probably not because there wouldn't be
enough band in order to get it in here.
So like going this way, for
example, let me take another color
before this gets too complicated,
like coming this way would bend like
that and it miss your eye. However,
there are situations in which you
see two images of the same object,
one from each side. These are
called gravitational lenses.
Uh, many, many images, uh,
in principle,
if it's lined up exactly right,
imagine that it's perfectly
aligned. Uh, then,
uh,
you see this way,
you see that way and you see out of
the paper and you can see a whole ring.
This has actually been observed,
not the whole ring, but,
but large parts of the ring because
it's an, it's never perfectly aligned.
Uh, but, uh, you can see
these things. These are called
Einstein Einstein's ranks,
and you can actually see them. Uh, you
can see these kinds of multiple images,
uh, in cases where, uh,
this is a very distant galaxy or quasar.
Quasars are, are, uh, uh, uh, very bright,
very small extra galactic objects.
And this is an intervening
galaxy or galaxy cluster.
And you can see these multiple images.
I'll bring some pictures in next time.
They're very, they're, they're
amazing looking things. Uh,
it's often true that you can see
four images that comes about when the
intervening mass is not spherical.
Uh,
and so you get weird deflections
and they're multiple directions.
You see the same object,
a very spectacular thing.
These were discovered only recently.
Uh, but it turns out that there's,
that you can observe this effect even
in our own solar system because what you
can do, I'll bring in some
pictures of gravitational lenses.
Those are, those are
amazing things. Uh, and uh,
what also happens is if you're looking
at something big like a galaxy that has a
shape, it distorts the shape. It's
stretches the whole thing out.
You get these amazing pictures.
All right? In any case, in our own,
in our own solar system,
you see this in the following way.
Here's The sun,
and here's a star right behind the song.
Uh,
and the light from the
star comes like this.
And so you think the stories here.
So if you look at, uh, at a star,
when it's right next to the sun,
right at the edge of the sun,
it seems to be in a different position
relative to stars further relative to
other stars up here.
Here's another star, uh,
than it would if you looked at it at
night when the sun wasn't in the way.
Yes. How do you do daytime? Excellent
question. I'm getting to that.
Uh, okay. So, but the principle is
supposedly the sun were dark. Okay.
Uh,
look at star behind the sun
or right next to the sun.
Really? You can't through
the sun. I'm not that crazy.
A star behind son.
Uh,
and it appears
to be in a different place position
then when observed,
uh, at night without the sun in
the way. Okay. So how do you,
how do you do astronomy during the
daytime? That's a good question. Eclipses,
yes. You wait until there's a solar
eclipse and then you do your observation.
Uh,
do this by observing
during an eclipse.
And if you do this,
the position,
the change in position of the star,
uh,
if it's right at the edge of the
sun and you've now blocked the sun,
cause here's the moon, right?
And the light from the sun
doesn't come through. Uh,
this change in position that's an
ankle is around one arc second.
And that, that's a positional
change. Who can observe,
remember the size of the
apparent size of a star.
When you look at it,
it's about one arc second.
So it seems like it's shifted
a significant amount. Uh,
and so you go,
you take a,
you take a picture of the sky of the stars
behind the sun during a total eclipse
of the sun. Now the problem with
this is a practical problem. Uh,
total eclipses of the sun happen only
for very short amounts of time. And,
uh,
only occasionally and only in a small,
over a small portion of
the earth at any one time.
How many people have seen an eclipse
of the sun? Pretty spectacular thing,
Huh? Uh, but you know, you
have to travel to get there.
It doesn't come to you. So
here's what happened. In 1917,
Einstein publishes,
uh,
his theory of general relativity.
And then in 1919,
there's going to be an eclipse in Brazil.
I think it was,
uh,
eclipse in Brazil. And, uh,
it seems like a good idea that you
should actually go and test this theory,
which has made a very specific
prediction about what, uh,
what ought to be going on with these,
uh, with these stars. So Eddington,
we've heard of him before.
He's the guy who trashed his student,
Chandra Sacar some years later. Uh, but
at the time he was young, up and coming,
British scientist, uh,
mountain expedition, uh,
to Brazil to test this theory
to Brazil. And it works. Goes down there.
He takes these pictures.
It does just what Einstein,
and this is the event that makes
Einstein into a great international,
uh, figure there. This is front
page headlines around the world.
And part of the reason why it
was, is look at these dates. Uh,
Einstein is a German scientist.
This is the middle of World War One A.
And so in the middle of World War One,
the German side to seize later thought
of as a Jewish scientist, but that, uh,
but at the time, uh, Hitler
was not yet on the scene.
And so Einstein was thought
of as a German scientist.
So this German scientists
publishes a grand,
bizarre new theory of the
universe right after the war,
the Brits Mountain operation to go
and check and see if this is right.
And it turns out to be correct.
So this is now right after World War
one in the era when everybody thought,
well, we're never going to have a
war again. There's going to be peace,
a peace and justice and brotherhood
throughout the world for the rest of time.
And as part of this,
the British,
a mountain expedition to confirm
a German theory of science.
And this is regarded
as a huge sign of the,
a great new future that we're moving
into of international cooperation.
And a consequence of this,
this is front page news all over the
world and it makes Einstein famous.
This is what makes Einstein
famous. So, uh, uh,
the fable here is the
1919 eclipse expedition.
And the moral that was drawn at the time,
uh,
is the great international, uh,
is how science is this wonderful,
uh,
international,
maybe even universal,
a quest.
Uh, and in retrospect, what it is,
it's a great demonstration
of, uh, uh, you know,
how scientists opposed to work
new theory makes a prediction.
You go out and measure the effect
and it works. Uh, so this is, uh,
uh, uh, science works as advertised,
except, you know, maybe
it doesn't because, uh,
subsequently in, in, in
subsequent years, people
looked back at the apparatus
that Eddington and his
team had put together and
said,
you know,
you can't actually make measurements
that accurate with this stuff.
So how were they able to make this
measurement? And oddly enough,
for about 50 years,
the photographic plates,
what they'd done was taking photographs
at the sky had disappeared. Uh,
and so nobody could go back and check
the original data at some point.
Subsequently,
that kind of reappeared in saw
just recently actually inside,
uh,
the personal effects of a
British astronomer who had
gone to live in Chile and
nobody quite knows how he got ahold of
them. Uh, and I actually have to say,
I'm not sure what the outcome of this is,
whether people have actually gone back and
tried to measure this again. Uh, so, uh,
and at the time,
you know,
Eddington who in in his subsequent life
demonstrated a real propensity for,
uh, believing his own theories,
if you know what I mean,
which in which served him poorly when
he was dealing with Chandra Saker,
who was thinking of other things
Eddington had said before he went on the
expedition that he was absolutely
certain this was going to work. Uh,
because he had studied Einstein's theory
and had come to believe it because it
was so beautiful and elegant.
And so, uh, there's a famous,
there's a famous story where somebody
said, well, Mr Addington, what will, uh,
or said to somebody
else on the expedition,
what will adding to do if it comes
out wrong? And he said, well, addict,
we'll just go in say,
uh,
and so there's a little bit of
suspicion to attach to this particular,
uh, experiment. However,
subsequent to that,
this has been measured repeatedly,
many times during many eclipses. And,
uh, it's very clear that
this works. And as I said,
there's now evidence from
other astronomical objects
for the deflection of light.
All of which confirms, uh,
Einstein's theory. Yes.
What is the second line?
Say? Uh, let's see. Uh,
eclipse expedition scientist and
international universal quest,
uh, science works as
advertised. Maybe. Uh,
that's what I was trying to write down.
So that's the second post Newtonian test.
And the fact that it works in 1919
is what makes people really believe
relativity. And what makes people
believe that Einstein's, this, this, uh,
intense genius.
Okay.
There are a couple of other posts,
Newtonian effect.
So here's now a post
Newtonian effect number three,
and this is something called
the gravitational red shift.
You've heard of a red shift,
redshift and blue shifts.
They come about because of the doppler
shift. Something moves towards you.
It's like gets shifted to the blue.
Something moves away from you,
it's like get shifted to the red.
Turns out the wavelengths
of light also change,
um,
due to gravity or due to being
emitted in a curved space time.
If you want to use the
relativistic formulation,
basically, here's how it works.
Uh, you have some object
with radius r, uh,
mass m and you have a light source
on the surface of that object. Uh,
and you look at it from a distance.
You're out here at infinity watching
this light and, uh, the light,
if you emit green light, uh,
by the time it reaches you,
it'll have shifted into the
rep and there's an equation.
Let me write down the equation.
So this is Delta Lambda.
Oops,
that one's not working anymore.
Delta Lambda over lambda zero.
That's, that's the shift in light.
And remember that the doppler shift
has some equation here. We'll,
here's the equation, uh, for,
uh,
this shift due to the gravitation
of an object are s over our,
uh,
where this is the distance
to the given mass,
uh, or, uh, if you're emitting
light from the surface of an object,
the distance to the masses, the distance
to the center of the object. Uh,
so in this particular case, it would be
the radius of the object, uh, minus one.
So you can see that if there is no mass,
uh,
then the swatch showed radius is zero,
and this is one minus one,
and there's no shift. Okay?
Now, why does this happen?
This has to happen.
Uh,
imagine that you're standing
on the surface of an object
and you throw an object
up into the air. I have an object
here. Uh, I'm going to do this.
What will happen as I throw it
up into the air, it's going to,
it's going to slow down.
If I throw it faster than the escape
velocity and I don't have a ceiling and
stuff, then it'll go, it'll
keep going away forever,
but it will nevertheless slow down.
Uh,
if I throw it up slower
than the escape velocity,
then it's going to rise to some height,
stop turning around and fall back. Right?
So that's what, that's what happens
with an object. Why is this happening?
The reason it happens is
because, uh, as it moves,
as it tries to move away from the earth,
it has to lose energy because it's
pushing its way out of the gravitational
field.
Uh,
and so it gradually slows down because
it's kinetic energy decreases as it goes
further away to balance the
change in the potential energy.
For those of you who
remember high school physics,
it balances the change in potential
energy though the total energy is zero.
And so the kinetic energy
has to slow down, uh,
and whether it slows down
enough to stop it or not,
depends on whether it's moving faster
than its escape velocity or not.
Supposing I do this with a flashlight
and instead of throwing a key chain up in
the air,
I throw a photon up in the air and the
photon starts out at the speed of light.
Now,
uh,
that too has to lose energy
and it moves away from,
from the earth. But light, as we know,
always travels at the speed of light. It
doesn't slow down. It can't slow down.
So what it has to do is it to
lose energy in some other way.
And the trick is that
the energy of a photon,
yeah,
is equal to a couple of constants.
H Times see over the wavelets.
So as the energy gets less,
the wavelength gets longer,
has to get bigger.
And so what is happening here is as you
shine light off of gravitating object,
as it gets further and further away
from the object, it loses energy,
but it loses energy,
not by slowing down as an
ordinary massive objects would,
but by changing its wavelength.
And now go back and look
at this equation again.
Supposing you're shining your
flashlight from, uh, the,
from the event horizon of a black hole,
from a something where the,
the distance to the object is
equal to the Schwab chilled radius.
Then you get down to the lambda equals
infinity and you've read shifted your way
out to an infinitely large wavelength.
The consequence of that is that the
energy of the light is equal to zero.
And so this is how, uh, how it happens.
That light can't escape from
a black hole because you know,
if you have the new Tony Envision of the
escape philosophy in mind, then goes up,
stops,
turns around and comes back
and you imagine shining a
flashlight from inside the
event horizon of a black hole.
You imagine that the light would go up,
stop turnaround and fall back,
but like doesn't do that.
Cause light always goes at the speed
of light. So what happens instead?
Is it red shift itself out
of existence altogether? Uh,
and so that's the way a light is
prevented from leaving a black hole.
Because if you shine from
either inside or, uh, uh,
at the event horizon, it'll red
shift itself to infinity. Yeah,
still makes perfect sense.
Uh, okay. So, and then there is a,
there is a Newtonian version of this.
You can imagine how you expand this, uh,
this thing. But this particular
equation is relativistic.
Uh, oh. The other thing is that
of course in Newtonian physics,
there's no reason for
enlightened not to slow down.
Okay.
This business, that light always
goes at the speed of light,
regardless of the observer is a
relativistic effect. So, you know,
if you take a photon and throw it
in the air in a Newtonian concept,
there's no reason it can't slow
down and turn around and come back.
Yes.
Yeah.
Delta Lambda over Lambda
Delta Lambda overlapped as
this.
Okay.
So this is speed of light.
Uh,
and this is another famous
constant called Planck's constant,
uh,
weren't,
I don't think we're going to use that
equation for anything in particular, but,
but it's,
it's a couple of constants.
So basically the energy is
proportional to one over lambda.
Yeah.
Other questions?
Okay. Uh, if you turn it around,
if you sit on the surface of,
I don't know,
a neutron star or something
and look at distant star light,
that light will pick up energy
as it comes towards you.
And so if you sit on up gravitating
object and look at a distance like distant
light,
that light will actually be blue shifted
because it will gain energy falling
down towards you. Uh, and so, uh,
while this is always referred to
as the gravitational redshift,
cause we're always imagining that we're
some distant observer in a flat space
looking at some gravitating
object in principle,
if you could live on a neutron
star, a, all the stars,
all the stars would look bluer than
they do to us because of this effect.
So it works both ways. This, by the way,
has now been tested
in the laboratory.
Here's how you do it. Uh,
you set up,
you sit on top of a ladder and you look
at light coming from the surface and uh,
coming up towards you. And then
you have somebody, you have some,
some confederate or graduate
student or something, uh,
who sits on the ground and looks
at light coming sideways, uh,
and you determined that the wavelength
detected here is slightly larger than the
wavelength detected here.
That's a really small effect because the
Earth's gravitational field, you know,
if you do this little calculation and
you're trying to figure out our ass over
our for the surface of the earth,
uh, it's a really, really small,
small difference from one.
Nevertheless,
because you're in the laboratory and we
know how to measure the wavelengths of
light with incredible accuracy, uh, this
can, this effect can actually be measured,
uh, in, in the lab and has been,
yes,
if you're on a black hole or whatever,
shining a light awkward and it,
instead of doing the arc thing just
stretches out and weeks out
of existence at the top,
then went back into the systems.
Well, it can't fall back, right? It can't,
it can't fall back because he can't stop,
turn around and come back
out of existence up here.
Well, notice what happened. Uh,
supposing you go from,
uh,
from the event horizon only to
slightly above the event horizon. Uh,
the difference in,
uh,
in the wavelength you see is this
quantity at the event horizon minus this
quantity a little bit above the event
horizon because it's still going to be red
shifted.
But this is infinite if the event horizon,
so by the time it moves even a tiny bit
off the event horizon has already gone.
Okay.
Yeah. It's because this goes, this
term becomes infinitely large.
Uh, oh, but I should say, uh,
this brings up a good
point. Supposing, uh,
supposing you're here and it's not
a black hole, so it's not going to,
it's not going to be disastrous,
but you're observing it.
Not An infinity but close. Uh,
so here's this is that, uh,
some are, and this is it r one
a little bit further away. Uh,
so what you would observe here is Delta
Lambda over over lambda is equal to a
Delta Lambda at our one minus delta.
Let me write this so that there's
some hope of reading it. Um,
so this gives you,
uh,
the Delta Lambda you observe at our one,
over lambda is equal to Delta Lambda
at our one calculated by that for me,
a minus Delta Lambda at our,
uh, because it red shifts a
little bit from here to here.
It would red shift more
from here out to infinity.
And so the way you calculate that as
you calculate red shift from here to
infinity minus redshift from
here to infinity, uh, aunt,
since for something that is
at, uh, the event horizon,
the red shift from there to infinity
to infinity is infinite. Uh,
even if you're observing it just a
little bit higher, uh, it's already gone.
Does that make sense?
How are we doing other questions?
Yes.
Oh, the photons. Remember there's
a relationship between the fo the,
the whole way wave particle
duality works for photon.
There's a relationship between the energy
of the photon and the wavelength that
was this equals HC over lambda thing.
So as the wavelength becomes infinite,
the energy in that photon goes to zero.
So it's still a photon.
But if you've got a photon with zero
energy and you're not going to notice it,
um, yes, you know,
use the gravitational field.
It was like the mercury or whatever
miss slingshot probes is an outer space.
Could light,
like pick up energy by
going around massive object.
Well, it pays like picks up energy as it
falls towards a massive object. That's,
that's the,
the inverse gravitational redshift.
Do you sit on the gravitating object?
You watched light coming at you
from a distance. So it does that.
That slingshot effect only works if
you add energy to the thing that kick
yourself back out of orbit
at just the right moment.
You can't do that with light because
you can't give it extra. Uh, uh, uh,
you can't give it an extra velocity kick
at any moment to, to, to push it back up.
But it is true that if you sit
and you can do this, uh, you can,
you can do this experiment backwards,
right? You have your light source up here,
uh, and you observe it from down here
and then you'll see a blue shift. It
other questions.
How are we doing?
Okay. Uh, let me mention one last, uh,
uh, post Newtonian effect.
This is post Newtonian a fact.
Uh,
number four,
and this is the existence
of gravitational waves.
Uh,
and the way this works is these over here,
remember the, the, the,
the bed sheet and the basketball over
here from a few days ago. All right?
Now imagine that that basketball,
which is some massive object is
moving back and forth. Um, the,
it's orbiting some other thing on that
bed sheet. What will happen? Well,
the bed sheet, we'll, we'll,
we'll ripple in different ways as
the thing moves around. And this, uh,
creates,
uh,
essentially a wave of distortions
of spacetime. The propagates,
uh, at, uh, propagates outward as it
turns out at the speed of light. So, uh,
the way this works is, uh, as a mass,
uh,
moves back and forth,
perhaps because it's an orbit
or for some other reason,
it generates ripples
in space time.
These propagate outward
at the speed of light. Uh, and we'll
talk later maybe about how one, uh,
what it means to have a ripple in
space time and how one might detect it.
But there's a more immediate effect,
which is that the energy
in these so called gravitational waves,
they carry energy with them and the
energy comes from is extracted from the
orbit of the object that's
moving back and forth.
So the orbit gradually loses energy
and that means the orbit gets smaller
gradually.
So the orbit gets gradually smaller.
Uh,
and so in the Newtonian approximation
thinks stay in orbit and they're perfectly
stable forever and ever, and they just
go orbiting around and around and around.
But in general, relativity, there's a,
if there's a gradual slow loss of energy
and objects will gradually spiral in.
Now this happens really slowly.
It has not been detected in the
solar system. That is to say,
even the orbit of mercury.
Uh,
we can't measure it's orbital period
accurately enough to see this slow down.
Certainly all the planets in the solar
system have been happily going in their
orbits for four and a half billion years,
uh,
with no sign of this
effect. But you can, uh,
see us see this in certain
kinds of binary stars,
stars with which happened
to have very short orbits.
And in particular, uh, there's
something called the, uh,
binary, Paul Sahre, Paul, sorry,
is a kind of neutron star, uh, and, uh,
these gravitational wave effects,
the gradual decrease in the orbit,
uh, has been observed in binary
pulsars. And we'll talk about that,
I guess a next time.